everyone's like what the heck whoa
that's crazy at first i was like
why is he why is he not winning
oh my gosh everything is right in the
world because cobra kai is back for
season four
we gotta take things to the next level i
want to talk about the finale because
that all valley tournament just blew my
mind we had eli versus robbie and eli
came out on top what was your reaction
to that and then i'll tell you what
tanner just told me well i wasn't very
surprised that eli would beat robbie um
i think nine times and that fight would
have gone the same way uh no it was
really cool i was super surprised even
at the beginning of the season i was
talking to show low and i was like oh
yeah i'm at the tournament it's gonna be
you and tanner and i don't know who's
gonna win but both you guys got plot
armor so you're gonna win you know and
then when we found out that i was the
one that won
everyone's like what the heck whoa
that's crazy but you know as as i should
be as i am i can jump the highest so i
feel like i should be the one that wins
the trophy oh yes because if it all
comes down to who can jump the highest
that's yeah wait what did what did
tanner say tanner was like i was really
bummed
at first i was like why is he why is he
not winning going into the season i was
like robbie's gotta win robbie's gotta
win he's he's he's been beat down every
single season and this is gonna be his
one thing
and then i kept talking to the writers
and like mary said i think there was
multiple endings and they decided on
that ending and i got it
i was definitely reading i was like and
no he loses okay well great
this is
okay this is fine this is i'm okay
he's over there spilling his guts and
you're here yeah i win nine times out of
ten he sucks whatever
i'm sorry that's just the world kid all
right i do want to talk about the fact
that hawks wings were clipped in season
four that was a really tough scene for
me to watch i feel like i've become
desensitized to the fact that these
teens beat the crap out of each other
but giving someone a haircut without his
consent was really harrowing what was
your reaction to that and do you miss
your long locks they had talked about
doing that even in season one but it was
more kind of jokey like oh what would
happen if the huck didn't have his hawk
you know um and then when
that became a reality it sort of felt
like it happened too soon and i was like
no like i'm not ready like i don't want
to lose it yet but yeah it was it was
weird that scene was
uh
hard to do
it felt weird just like i i kept
thinking like no i would get up i
wouldn't let this happen like not like
this but i think it allowed for a lot of
growth for eli you know um i think this
is the first time i felt confident and
comfortable as eli
in the character like just him as
himself like he felt good about himself
and that's the first time i ever felt
that so that was fun it was it was good
to have that moment tournament well and
i love jacob as you were answering that
answer that show low just took off his
hat to reveal his long locks yeah i'm
like are you are you auditioning is it
yeah exactly i'm ready to
i think uh
have the hawk next
pass down the torch oh my gosh well
let's talk about the fact that in the
final moments of season four miguel hops
on a bus
he is leaving his two father figures
behind in search of his real dad in
mexico city who we find out knows
nothing about him which is a really
interesting twist what was your reaction
when you read that finale ending at the
time of us like finding out or i guess
myself finding out about that moment
like the creators were still deciding
what was going to happen with that like
i i've heard so many different versions
of what happens you know directly after
hopping on that bus that i was really
like i don't know what to think like
yeah i guess i have my own ideas but
they they really were like not sure as
to what that was gonna happen they were
just like we know that he's gonna hop on
a bus to mexico
after that
we don't know you know like we don't
know if he makes it if he doesn't make
it
that was like well come on i left the
tournament for this like come on tell me
tell me something good happens like tell
me it was worth it uh i was like i
didn't you know lose that i came back
from being paralyzed come on guys hey
come on hey get through it you're
kidding me but you know i do
have a lot of uh respect for our
creators and everything that they've
kind of compiled and you know even even
after getting thrown off of a balcony
somehow they managed to redeem my
character so so i i have a i have a lot
of trust in them and i know that
regardless as to what happens you know
after the events that'll all kind of be
worth it and they'll do it in a way
that's unexpected but also uh satisfying
and feels fulfilling we're gonna take
back the valley take it back in a
measured and organized approach we bite
first this season you guys stepped up
your training game even higher i didn't
know that was possible gianni look at
dimitri go
season one dimitri getting his backpack
dumped in a pile of yogurt to now you
know rocking the commas and kind of
holding his own in the old valley it's
i'm proud i'm proud of the guy i'm proud
too did your training have to step up
along with dimitri's because i know that
you are more advanced than he is yeah no
it definitely had to step up uh season
one uh dimitri didn't do or i didn't do
any training whatsoever and i just kind
of watched these guys do and i was like
damn i really want to do that and then
kind of season two i got to do a little
bit more and then more and then more and
then doing training for season four was
just crazy we had a lot of uh crazy
stunts to do and like i said the commas
alone that that took a long time yeah
just at home
you know flipping those things ruining
my hardwood floors it's great come on
we're gonna get sued here uh sue me for
what
tighten that cord cause you guys are
already wrapping up season five right
now what can you tease what are you
allowed to tell me oh hawk dies
i'll die yeah the final installment for
this character yeah finally finally the
first episode actually it's a cold open
i actually take the rest of his mohawk
and spray sprinkle it over his grave
so it's beautiful it's a really touching
moment yeah it is really good and it's
fun because they got um they allowed me
to come back as a ghost and i am
constantly visiting like a phoenix so
instead of a hawk he's a phoenix rising
from the house
yes it's actually we're doing a
crossover with the walking dead so he
does rise up again yeah yeah
love that but really though what can you
tell me any little tease about season
five what should fans expect for this
next season well you guys don't know
anything about season oh wait no this is
coming out after after yeah there's some
fights there's some fights
there's yeah we have fights
kobakai
hates miyagido in the end they really do
not like miyagido at the end oh i take
my hair off at some point i take my
shirt off at some point actually had a
lot of points yeah there's actually
doesn't wear a shirt in the fifth season
there's nothing more emasculating than
you taking off your shirt jacob
i feel empowered that's my time guys
thank you so much
that's the note we're gonna end it on
just that jacob apparently has his
clothes painted on in season five yeah
wonderful thanks guys